are you one of the many international
couples
perhaps living outside your country of
origin benefiting from free movement
and the opportunity to study and work in
the eu
if your relationship breaks down it
might become more complex
it is important that your children have
a personal relationship and regular
contact
with both parents who might no longer
live in the same country
by talking with your partner you'll be
able to agree on important custody
aspects
such as your children's living
arrangements finances
schooling and visiting rights if you
need additional support to reach an
agreement
you can approach an expert mediator
family lawyer
or your child welfare authority if you
are unable to agree in this way
and you need to go to court eu rules
will help to determine which court is
the right one to hear your case
once the court has decided on parental
responsibility its enforcement will be
made easier in any other eu country
for more information and help on making
the best decision for all
visit the family section of the european
e-justice portal